michael vsauce here and the earth is
actually flat don't believe me take it
pewdiepie what if the earth is in fact
flat and science has been wrong all
along thank you there you go there you
have it the earth is actually flat come
on gravity if gravity is real then how
come I can't see it huh
where is it I'm still looking if Isaac
Newton was so smart then how come he's
dead
all these pseudo-intellectuals so
blindly biting into what the word of
science is telling them and believe that
the earth is round like a ball well if
earth is round like a ball then why are
cars like this and not like this the
earth is flat you may think ha ha that's
a meme oh no no no no it is not a meme
it's science fact my guy Bob the rapper
tweeted the cities in the background are
approximately 60 miles apart where is
the curb please explain this yes of
course Bob here is exciting extremely
solid evidence I can I can definitely
make out what it says in this picture
this is irrefutable evidence I don't
understand why we're even talking about
this where is the car typical political
jumping on anything train wagon Neil
deGrasse Tyson just had to bite into the
conversation Belarus is ggggg silly Neil
you know you don't know what you're
talking the completely unlikable
chipmunk Tila Tequila joining the
conversation as well I will stop my Flat
Earth Talk if someone could send me a
goddamn photo of the horizon with the
curvature that's right if it if I don't
see a photograph of a curve then
everything else if earth isn't flat
why are shoes like this and not like
this
if earth isn't flat why can PT Pais
chair do this but not this oh yeah
but can't you do that if earth isn't
flat then why am i wearing headphones
when there's no audio if ours isn't flat
we're a computer mouse like this and not
like this
if others in flat why are cars like this
and not like diamond mine cards can we
stop wasting our time NASA is not
spending enough money on space
exploration it's all been taken over by
corporation but the government needs to
thrive the government was first were we
not the first ones on the moon well how
could we christen moon is nearly just a
pizza slice if earth is flat then why
titties like these round and voluptuous
and not like these flat like a taste way
oh listen to this one
gay gay sons if earth is flat then why
are rainbows like this huh then not like
this huh your move LGBTQ community hmm
we've heard the answer from the science
community but what about the LGBT
community everything's flat then why
your mom look like this and not like
this if earth is flat why I'm elected
and non-elected
if earth was flat would have pushed
everything off by now
some silly girl in bikini says excuse me
have you not seen this photo excuse me
this photo is evidenced by itself the
Flat Earth Society has members all
around the globe I mean on all on the
pizza slice we are it's all on the flat
door Club it's a flat globe shut wonder
why the dinosaurs all disappeared huh
well okay well well they all went to
space of course silly science community
if the earth is round how do you explain
this half checkmate actually someone
should make an anime where the planets
in our solar system are acute anime
girls attending school and there's a
running gag where F Chan is
self-conscious about her smaller chest
to which she constantly responds I am
NOT playing everybody called me flying
ah don't believe what they say senpai
you are not flat see this is what I'm
talking about if the earth is round and
voluptuous then why is earth chain so
flat
neither flat or round there are people
who believe earth is don't know how to
shut the [ __ ] up Jesus Christ it's time
to rate the meme everybody it gets it
gets a pizza slice one but a really good
one that is not my that is not microwave
the next meme is also another older meme
but I need 10 minutes so let's just get
right into it
crying markiplier means yes
[Music]
it's so sad it was this song is so sad
by itself but you add a crying mark
apply to the corner and it is instantly
the tragedy of our generation I cannot
hold withhold the tears as you can tell
by my teeth
[Music]
it's
that was when
[Music]
you can put crying markiplier over
literally anything and it will turn the
happiest thing into sand because there's
nothing more sand than a crying murca
plane oh no a hope adding a cry
markiplier is basically the equivalent
of a sad piano you can't just not cry
[Music]
the crying markup I mean we of course so
sad because who would purposely cry on
camera I would never do that I just have
too much testosterone in my body that I
would never allow myself to cry in front
of an audience when there's a camera
presence whenever I do have to cry I
make sure there's no cameras around me
thank you very much I have never cried
on camera and I never will and that's
why I laugh at this crying markiplier
meme thank you
[Music]
oh come on I still say it
so saying this meme this meme is so sad
I'm writing it so sad it's gets a so sad
rating meme review next meme comes from
other youtuber steven crowder he has a
serious on youtube where he debates
other people on controversial topics
here's one where he says male priviledge
ism it changed my mind with this photo
in mind that can so easily be altered
beautiful memes came out of it
just beautiful means he is starting to
buzz change my mind
your wife is fresh change my Mane this
meme will be forgotten in a week changed
my mind
now this is a great meme it's gotta
transcend all other memes it's stronger
than the you gonna knuckle meme that's
for sure
traps are not gay change my mind now
this is some really controversial topics
we're getting into now Jar Jar Binks is
a sisterhood changed my mind
your mom gay no you yeah this meme is
definitely gonna be dead hey but can you
do this
changed my mind for only 399 that's a
meme review next one please
oh it would seem that we are done